[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mardi 19
février des oeuvres sacrées maturité
atteinte vers l'âge de 30 ans le peintre
philippe lejeune est au coeur de la
nouvelle exposition de versailles à
l'espace riccio plus de 150 oeuvres sont
rassemblés pour la troisième année
consécutive renseigne recherche des
jeunes talents un tremplin pour sept
groupes lycéens l'occasion de jouer dans
des conditions professionnelles et une
de ces sélections se déroule en mai dans
les yvelines à bord d'un navire échoué
des survivants qui subissent la tyrannie
de leur capitaine jusqu'au soulèvement
la compagnie petric présent voilà là où
le crépuscule des dieux à la ferme de
bel ébat et nous recevrons aussi
françois gros band le directeur du big
band arcis swing de bois d'arcy qui
célèbre cette année ses 30 ans 10 ans de
peinture à travers 150 tableaux philippe
lejeune était un artiste prolifique
acquis versailles rend hommage dans sa
nouvelle exposition l'espace
richaud permet de découvrir l'oeuvre
d'une vie celle d'amp entre symbole de
la permanence d'un art sacré
une rétrospective inédite d'un peintre
né en 1924 à montrouge philippe lejeune
est formée aux ateliers d'art sacré au
moment où ils sont en train de
disparaître
il est l'un des derniers élèves de
maurice denis qui va mourir tragiquement
dans un accident de la route mais il
aura quand même connu deux ans ce qui va
suffire pour
lui inculquer tout parce que c'était
surtout un théoricien maurice denis et
le jeune va mettre assez longtemps à
assimiler tout ce que lui a dit maurice
denis et tout ça va ressortir plus tard
[Musique]
une actualisation des sujets bibliques
le jeune représente les membres de sa
famille on retrouve ses propres traits
le traite sous les traits de son père et
notamment les traits de sa jeune épouse
les initiants suite au cubisme philippe
lejeune développe une peinture
probabiliste le tableau à son propre
pouvoir créateur ce que delacroix appelé
la musique du tableau philippe lejeune
l'a poussé à son paroxysme le sujet fini
par disparaître sous l'harmonie et c'est
surtout nourrie d'influencés une
influence indirecte qui est une
influence de lorient parce qu'il se
trouve qu'il a été à calcutta en voiture
dans une petite 4l tout seul et il a été
là frappé par la spiritualité
qui régnait
en inde et sa rencontre avec le père
laborde aussi a été a été extrêmement
importante
la cité de la joie
et c'est
après cela que sert d'inspiration va
être de plus en plus mystique en fait
avocat lipstick philippe lejeune est
devenu maître de son art aux alentours
de 30 ans plus de 150 tableaux issus des
collections familiales sont aujourd'hui
rassemblés à l'espace richaud si vous
avez gardé une âme d'enfant cette
exposition est pour vous aux
clayes-sous-bois les lego ont envahi
l'espace philippe noiret des dizaines de
petites briques issus des collections
personnelles des adhérents de
l'association breezy briques sud
yvelines
à voir jusqu'au 3 mars prochain un nom
avec le président de l'association
ainsi nokia jamais repartie avec un
diorama sur l'egypte on a un dorama sur
les certain temps avec plusieurs
véhicules et des totems de tatin on a
une reproduction d'un aquarium les
dioramas sur du marvel super heroes et
après de différentes voitures exposées
et en plus ils pourront participer donc
il y a
un ensemble avec des briques libre où il
comme pour réaliser toutes leurs envies
et une piscine à dupes locaux et si vous
faisiez votre première scène au mois
d'août pour la troisième année le
festival rock en seine cherche de
nouveaux talents
le tremplin des lycéens est de retour et
les talents seront sélectionnés à
l'issue de scènes ouvertes l'une d'entre
elles aura lui à l'usiné à chapeaux de
rambouillet matthieu beaumont soir
bonsoir mélanie alors vous êtes
assistant du pôle musique de l'usiné à
chapeaux déjà comment le site en est
venu à être partenaire de ce rock en
seine alors en fait la vie celle usine à
chapeaux est partenaire de ce dispositif
pour la deuxième année consécutive
donc c'est un partenariat qui est menée
avec donc le festival rock en seine dans
le cadre de dispositifs premières scènes
ainsi qu'avec la région ile de france
donc nous ça s'est fait naturellement
c'est quelque chose qui est plutôt
intéressant pour nous puisque ça
correspond tout à fait à nos missions
d'accompagnement des jeunes des jeunes
groupes groupes amateurs si vous voit
naître les grosses baffes et des parents
donc c'est vraiment ouvert à tous les
tous les jeunes lycéens et donc voilà
c'est un c'est un partenariat dont on
est assez fiers et qu'on poursuive pour
la deuxième année là l'année précédente
c'est donc un groupe de la région de
rambouillet était avait été sélectionnée
c'était et it in bloom donc c'est un
jeune groupe plutôt électro pop et donc
il n'avait plus joué sur la scène de
rock en seine c'est justement c'est
réservé qu'aux lycéens où on peut ouvrir
ce que dans des groupes souvent il ya un
peu de tout alors dans les conditions il
faut que 50% des banques du groupe soit
inscrit dans un établissement scolaire
donc en l'occurrence un lycée il faut
qu'ils aient moins de 22 ans pour lisser
un large puisque les prépas et tout ça
alors il ya une particularité ce que
souvent quand on commence on fait un peu
de reprise mais là dans ce tremplin il
faut quand même de l'originalité au
moins 50% tout à fait 50% de
compositions originales
il faut avoir un répertoire qui permet
de tenir on va dire entre 20 et 30
minutes
est ce qu'il ya une date limite pour
s'inscrire alors pour le 11 mai tout à
fait donc comme nous le rappelait le
tremplin se déroule le samedi 11 mai à
l'usiné à chapeaux et les inscriptions
se fait sur dossier d'inscription se
font pendant sur dossier d'inscription
jusqu'au samedi 20 avril et dont le site
s'est affichée en bas de l'écran alors
exactement
je pense qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de
candidatures mais tout le monde ne
passera pas le 11 mai j'ai fait
comprendre qu'un et qu'il y aurait déjà
une présélection exactement il y aura au
final six groupes qui seront retenus
pour la cession du 11 mai et le 11 mai
il y aura un jury et pas n'importe qui
alors les noms sont peut-être pas encore
nécessairement connus mais on sait plus
ou moins qui sera présent le profil web
d'affaires et donc il y aura un membre
d'un groupe on va dire éminent reconnu
et ayant participé au festival art rock
en seine il y aura un représentant de
l'organisation du festival et puis il y
aura des représentants du conseil des
musiciens qui est un organe propre à la
mjc composé de membres issus des studios
de la mjc et le 11 mai un sens il y aura
un gagnant d'offres et l'usiné à
chapeaux de son rôle ne s'arrêtera pas
là vous allez les accompagner jusqu'au
mois d'août exactement quelle manière
alors en fait donc le groupe qui sera
sélectionné bénéficiera de deux journées
totale complète d'accompagnement plus
une journée de répétition bien sûr ça
peut être un accompagnement qui peut se
faire sur différents voilà qui vend des
aspects ça peut être de l'accompagnement
scénique différentes différents aspects
du travail scénique et pour les cinq
autres il ne seront pas oubliés ils ne
seraient pas sur scène mais ils auront
des petits cadeaux c'est exactement un
des cadeaux de consolation ils pourront
participer au concert en tant que
spectateur et ils auront aussi quelques
on va dire quelques quelques bonus c'est
à dire ils pourront visiter les
backstage pour rencontrer ddd membres de
l'organisation ils font un peu voir
l'envers du décor d'europe en scène et
vous même hallucinant château vous avez
poussé des groupes peut-être à
candidater alors oui tout à fait on
incite les groupes utilisateurs de nos
studios notamment à s'impliquer dans
cette aventure et puis on essaie aussi
de développer le plus de partenariats
avec des lycées du 78 tous les listes
qui souhaitent se lancer dans l'aventuré
avec mes parents bouyer exactement non
c'est plutôt à la destinée aux lycéens
du territoire du 78 merci matthew goss
d'avoir accepté de colonisation alors
pour participer au tremplin on leur dit
rien de plus simple
j'ai lections des sites internet qui
s'affichent au bas de l'écran on
téléchargera le formulaire d'inscription
graphiste professionnel stéphane il a
beau temps a transformé sa passion pour
le comics en nouveaux métiers une envie
qui se concrétise petit à petit pour sa
prochaine convention direction chicago
au milieu des plus grands marylène
iapichino la rencontre et avec ses super
héros entre stéphanie et les super héros
c'est une histoire d'amour c'est lui
l'homme chauve souris qui la ramène à
ses désirs passer le film batman begins
et cette illustration de david espo ont
un effet immédiat
elle doit reprendre le dessin j'ai
replongé dans ma passion grâce à batman
et puis la grâce à battre pas bouffer
commencé à faire quelques petites
concessions à être invitée sur des
festivals comics un petit peu à droite
et à gauche de conventions en convention
stéphanie alias lucky star pseudo
hommage à sonder son petit chat se fait
connaître dans l'univers du comics lors
de la dernière comic con de paris elle
est finaliste du concours d'illustration
avec sont les nomme voilà j'ai été 3e
alors la troisième
j'étais hyper contente parfois en fait
je compte entourage qui était déçue pour
moi j'aime énormément je suis heureuse
j'ai fini troisième au concours de
dessin et j'étais la seule fille à être
retenus dans lés dans les 30
participants les 30 derniers sa
technique au stylo bic et aquarelles
impressionne le jury mais ce qui lui
plaît avant tout dans les conventions ce
sont les rencontres
j'étais en train de combattre iron man
et là en fait les deux enfants il était
face à
mais ils avisent si c'est ça qui est
génial dans les conventions c'est quand
les enfants ont fait rencontre le rire
ou quoi puis voilà bah ouais je peux pas
résister quand je croise batman son coup
de coeur pour batman ne serait rien sans
le soutien indéfectible de son mari
christian l'accompagnent à chaque
convention les guidant ses choix et
critique ses dessins alors ça nous a dit
hier avec mon mari
moi c'est le guy lux et star voilà
sociable et puis c'est rigolo maintenant
quand je suis invité en convention cette
faille christian il est là forcément mon
mari christian iv 1 bat windsor
son plus grand fan c'est mon fan numéro
c'est important en même temps cette
passion commune re découverte sur le
tard il la partage avec leurs amis et
les entraînent dans leur univers de
science-fiction pourtant bien éloignée
jamais avoir déguisé en wonder woman
c'est dire le couple d'architectes le
bien même en aide pour les perspectives
de ses dessins car stéphanie multiplie
les projets elle a été choisie par un
éditeur pour illustrer une histoire
d'amour dans une célèbre bd américaine
édité pour la première fois en france ne
l'a en ce moment elle travaille sur un
captain america à moto pour un livre
solidaire dont les bénéfices seront
reversés à une association d'enfants
malades
son plus grand projet c'est sa propre bd
le scénario lui est venu tout seul un
cauchemar qu'elle a précieusement noté
est conservé et donc du coup je fais une
architecture très sombre et très noir et
un peu plus les bâtiments bon genre
comme le film metropolis ou dark city
pour avoir quelque chose de très noir et
de très présent de très sombre et pour
dessiner son personnage principal
stéphanie s'inspire de son mari sont
vrais super héros
un bateau échoué à son bord un capitaine
qui règne en maître sur un équipage qui
l'a jadis sauver pas d'erreur sarah le
maire pas d'erreur c'est bien ça c'est
bien ça c'est bien le pitch alors vous
êtes la metteur en scène de ce spectacle
qui s'appelle valhalla 6une prononce
bien vous êtes accompagné aujourd'hui de
thomas 2 chauffour clown acrobate et
carlo massari performeur bonjour à tous
les trois déjà sarah le maire vous
signer donc cette mise en scène avec
anna nelson la genèse de ce projet on
avait envie de parler du pouvoir mais
d'une manière différente
déjà le ce que le pouvoir faisait sur
les gens ce qu'ils étaient capables de
de transformer chez quelqu'un et puis on
est parti du coup sûr l'idée de
révolution parce qu en fait au départ
les gens qui deviennent des dictateurs
avait des bonnes idées à la base et puis
on s'est dit qu'il se faisait quelque
part broyé par cette idée de pouvoir
donc pour parfaire sa est ce qu'on
faisait une révolution mais la
révolution du coup il faut un leader
caen le leader
si ça fonctionne il redevient dictateur
si ça fonctionne pas et qui meurt alors
de tout le mouvement meurent aussi
on était parti sur une idée de
soulèvement là où quelque chose pourrait
n'être ensemble en fait et donc on a
décidé de partir sur un bateau justement
par cette idée de l'univers ou enzo de
raisonner voilà qui se reconstituent
mais en micro société et c'est une image
de suicide de l'espèce humaine où il ya
un peu d'espoir je serai bonjour oui ça
c'est bon signe ça donc on fait des
utopies on vous montre ce qui va pas et
à la fin on laisse un arriver peut-être
un printemps mais ça c'est la suite
qu'il ne dessine c'est pas nous et ce
sont des faits divers des faits
d'actualité qui vous ont inspiré la
littérature la littérature
principalement et l'état général le
grand effondrement général d'ailleurs il
ya un truc assez drôle pour l'instant
c'est le nom qu'on a on est belge on a
créé en juin
donc les premières ont lieu en juin mais
ça fait suite à un processus d'un an de
création plateau est donc en juin on
joue la dernière scène où il ya une
tempête en fait on déclenche une tempête
et dans cette tempête un moment donné on
met des gilets et ses gilets sont jaunes
et en fait on parlait de ça nous c'est
quelque part c'est une sorte d'apologie
du système autogéré donc c'est une
utopie vers la est donc finalement
maintenant qu'on a commencé là la
tournée en janvier en ile de france vous
tombez en cours dans l'actualité à la
société voilà c'est pour ça qu'on a
continué à assumer ses gilets alors sur
scène six artistes qui sont circassiens
on en a deux avec nous pourquoi l'art du
cirque mis sur la scène comme on joue
aussi cette histoire là alors si je
pense que là c'est moi le circassien ici
je pense que ce que ce que le cirque
peut apporter par rapport à ça c'est que
ben on fait un peu de tout en fait il ya
un côté où on est à la fois acrobates
mais on peut toucher a plus faim aussi
un peu comédie un peu denses à un peu de
tout plein de trucs là un truc
du coup ça permet de créer 100 de trucs
plus globale je dis des bêtises
peut-être pas du tout sont pas dupes et
rédige que je n'ai pas nommer tout à
l'heure votre particularité c'est vous
mais les différents arts le cirque
il ya de la danse du théâtre de la vidéo
j'imagine qu'il faut du champ j'imagine
qu'il faut centraliser un peu tout ça
pour ressortir l'oeuvre c'est vraiment
mélange quand on fait un jeu dans les
plateaux etc nécessaires pour vraiment
raconter une histoire
je pense que dans la contemporanéité les
mélanges c'est surtout contemporain
c'est vraiment la contemporanéité c'est
fait c'est secret des mélange des
cultures des langues étaient tous et
donc beaucoup d art d dans le même
plateau
c'est magnifique et est ce que certains
artistes donc vous êtes circassiens ce
que vous avez dû apprendre des
techniques théâtrales peut-être où il ya
une transmission de savoirs entre les
différentes techniques
ça fait partie de la formation de
circassiens
par exemple la balle allait trois
circassiens nous sommes sur le plateau
on a tous les 3 es tu t'es dans la même
école à bruxelles que l'école supérieure
des arts du cirque et dans le cursus de
formation il ya du théâtre il ya de la
danse l'acrobatie la du trampoline c1
c'est vraiment une formation très large
des arts du spectacle on veut ça aussi
donc en fait on n'utilise pas les gens
pour ce qu'ils savent faire
en fait on a une histoire on raconte
quelque chose et on a des humains en
face et donc ils doivent chacun va vers
vers l'autre et vers la discipline de
l'autre en fait on veut pas qu'ils
aillent qu'on voit les coutures entre
des numéros de cirque du changement tout
sauf que comme on a l'image vision delà
de tout vous avez un spectacle une
immense vague et on a décidé de le
raconter avec ses différents médias
mais c'est pas on n'a pas pris du cirque
et du chant et du jeu non là on a fait
un mélange en fait avec ça donc c'est
difficile de savoir qui est sûr que
c'est un kiwi voilà qui est en fait
c'est pas c'est plus très définis chez
nous non plus quoi
mais alors il est pour qui ce valhalla
de public
oui on peut y aller pour les aider les
enfants pour leur apprendre aussi oui la
société qu il faut oui certaines d'entre
elles à plusieurs couches de lecture il
ya déjà dire qu'il ya des nuances plus
ou des références qui sont plus
culturelle que là c'est ce sera
principalement adressées aux adultes
quoique et mais on a vu en fait au fur à
mesure qu'on créait même pas forcément
ce spectacle psy mais les autres que ça
c'est des univers qui touchait assez
fort les enfants justement parce qu'on
est obligé de partir dans les idents de
plus tôt dans l'imaginaire vu qu'on
n'utilise pas le texte
il y en a mais on n'utilise pas il
raconte pas l'histoire en fait on a vu
au fur et à mesure que les enfants
accrochent plutôt vraiment bien et
personnellement moi un public d'enfants
je trouve ça c'est génial
ils réagissent beaucoup mieux quoi ils
réagissent comme le théâtre avant il
parle déjà
mais vous l'avez pensée pour eux ou peut
être pas du tout on a pensé un spectacle
en fait on pense oui c'est ce que ceux
qui ont envie de venir le voir viennent
le voir on n'a pas fait de distinction
c'est pas que pour les enfants que pour
les parents pas du tout
c'est un spectacle vous lisez le pitch
est est ce que lui celui que vous avez
fait l banques si ça vous intéresse
venez sinon rien de mieux pour conclure
merci à tous les trois leur valent
valhalla ou le crépuscule des dieux
c'est le titre entier c'est le 22
février prochain à la ferme de bel ébat
de guyancourt
[Musique]
2019 une année importante pour le big
band arcis swing il fête ses 30 ans un
anniversaire fêté dès ce jeudi 21
février lors de l'audition de jazz
françois gros bang
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes le
directeur du big band et de l'école de
musique est en fait les deux sont liés
des 210 voilà oui siège l'école de
musique depuis 1990 mais je suis arrivé
en tant que professeur de piano jazz en
1989 donc il ya exactement 30 ans et
j'ai monté dès la première année une
donc ce qui était à l'époque un ensemble
de jazz simplement d'une dizaine de
musiciens
comment vous est venue l'idée de le
monter c'est une envie de longue date
ah oui puis homme-là ont su gérer la
directrice de l'époque me l'a suggéré le
temps que je vois là j'ai fait ça
j'avais déjà dirigé des orchestres de
jazz bien entendu donc voila et puis au
départ c'était une ensemble d'une
dizaine de musiciens on a tout de suite
été sollicité par par la municipalité
par différents organismes pour aller
jouer pouvoir se produire un petit peu
partout il faut savoir quand même qu'il
ya 30 ans vidéo
au siècle dernier donc c'était le jazz
était encore très peu enseignée dans les
dans les conservatoires je pense qu'on a
tous une des rares structures sinon la
seule structure du département à
proposer du jazz donc je me rappelle
qu'on est celle du jouet big band s'est
développée probablement oui on était un
petit peu un pôle à cette époque-là bon
maintenant il ya du jazz un peu partout
je me rappelle qu'on était allé jouer au
conservatoire de versailles par exemple
et qu'à l'époque le directeur du
conservatoire de versailles m'avait dire
mais c'est formidable ce que vous faites
alors que maintenant bien entendu il ya
un département jazz tout à fait pas ton
conservateur au conservatoire de
versailles mais voilà à l'époque c'était
assez nouveau et aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas eu des musiciens avec vous
or donc après ça s'est développé ça
s'est développé grâce à deux atouts
formidables le premier à tous et qu'on
avait en effet eu la chance d'avoir un
daniel arte qui est un arrangeur
professionnels saxophoniste et arrangeur
professionnels qui nous était dédiée
donc été notre arrangeur personnel et
qui nous à cheveux qui nous a réalisé d
une quantité de d'arrangement magnifique
et qui a rangé à la demande quasiment
dans ce qui nous a permis de jouer dans
des contextes très différents on a par
exemple on a accompagné joël favreau qui
était le le guitariste de georges
brassens qui venait donner un concert au
théâtre de bonnart si on a accompagné
avec le big bang ce qu'il n'avait jamais
ce qui était une première puisqu'il n'y
avait pas d'arrangement fin connaisseur
de big band sur les chansons de georges
brassens
on a joué également on a été sollicités
tous les ans pour les pour le festival
pour le festival du cinéma de mémoire
des toiles de bonnard si donc on jouait
en clôture du festival donc à chaque
fois on apportait d'autres des deux
nouveaux arrangements sur des musiques
de films toujours des arrangements
personnels et puis petit à petit on a
intégré des des chanteurs et des
chanteuses et on a fait quelques
quelques réalisations assez assez
prestigieuse
il ya deux ans on a fermé gars big band
en réunissant 3 big band de trois
conservatoires quatre chorales d'enfants
voilà vous ne jouez pas que sur bois
d'arcy
non elle renonce à ses produits assez
souvent au petit journal montparnasse
donc c'était qu'il était qui
malheureusement n'est plus mais qui
était un haut lieu du jazz jazz parisien
et puis on est allés jouer effectivement
dans différents endroits en partenariat
avec d'autres d'autres conservatoire ou
bien
parce ont été sollicités pour pour
différents différents événements sur la
soirée du 21 février
j'ai cru un moment que vous allez jouer
quelques-uns de vos thèmes fétiches
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques exemples sont là tout dévoiler
voilà alors dont j'ai essayé de faire un
petit un petit melting-pot de tout ce
qui a été le grand moment du big bang
donc on va jouer tuque c'est de junction
qui est une que le thème qu'on avait
choisi comme thème d'ouverture
traditionnellement donc on a dû jouer 50
ou 100 fois voilà on va jouer une
musique de film donc une des musiques de
films des arrangements écrits par daniel
arte et puis on va jouer aussi des
nôtres alors cela il s'agit de il s'agit
de randgold qui prône également des
films butch cassidy et le kid et et on
prépare aussi pour le pour le concert
annuel alors du 30 du 30 mars et ce à un
hommage à michel legrand avec un extrait
des demoiselles de rochefort et et des
parapluies de cherbourg
même si françois gobât on a un peu pris
par le temps mais pour écouter le big
bang arcis ring pour découvrir un peu
puisque vous venez me dévoiler rendez
vous ce jeudi 21 février de 9h30 à 19h30
tout s'est affichée en bas de l'écran et
on passe maintenant à notre page agenda
[Musique]
un jeu-concours cinéma pour commencer à
l'occasion des projections de yao le
dernier film avec omar sy le grenier à
sel et rap vous font gagner des places
direction la page facebook de la ville
pour répondre à une question
le concours se termine demain mercredi
20 février à 14 heures les
clayes-sous-bois vous entraîne vers
l'est le gopac quartet est un voyage un
quatuor qui propose des chansons
folkloriques venus de russie d'ukraine
de moldavie de roumanie ou encore de
hongrie le concert a lieu ce vendredi à
20h30
ange est en tournée pour son 50e
anniversaire le plus intemporel des
groupes français sera ce vendredi à la
batterie de guyancourt il présentera
notamment son nouvel album e ressorti en
2018 on écoute un extrait
[Musique]
on termine avec un peu de magie de
l'illusion le québécois luc langevin
présente maintenant demain à la merise
de trappes ce vendredi de quoi découvrir
cet artiste qui mêle nouvelles
technologies poésie et mentalisme
regarder pour bien déjà la magie et la
science et deux entités complètement
posée pourtant les illusionnistes et les
scientifiques qui veulent exactement la
même chose
comprendre les secrets il faut être à la
fois scientifique et illusionnistes je
peux vous dire que c'est insupportable
pour moi ne pas comprendre le secret
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce site une culture
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi prochain
[Musique]